[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore azkaban and
the false imprisonment of sirius black
before we get started i just want to ask
that if you do enjoy the videos to
please like the video and subscribe if
you want as it helps with the algorithm
let's dive into it sirius hailed from
the powerful wizarding family the blacks
and while many of his family members
were advocates of blood purity sirius
did not share this same belief
many members of the black family would
follow very dark paths and sirius was an
exception to this
sirius black started at hogwarts in the
year 1971 the same year that peter
pettigrew remus lupin and james potter
began attending the school
the quartet of boys would eventually
form a group called the marauders and
one thing they all had in common was
that they were all gryffindors
before long the boys were graduating
from hogwarts and went on to join the
order of the phoenix a secret society
founded by albus dumbledore that opposed
lord voldemort the entire purpose of the
order was to oppose voldemort and the
death eaters and they were a vital
defense against their opposition during
the first wizarding war however it
turned out that not all members of the
order were good as sirius's old friend
peter pettigrew would go on to frame
sirius for a heinous crime in 1981
pettigrew murdered 12 muggles using a
dark and powerful blasting curse
simultaneously destroying hundreds of
feet of sewer system and leaving a
40-foot crater in the ground
someway somehow sirius black was blamed
and was promptly sent to azkaban after
being banished to azkaban seemingly the
whole world turned on serious even the
ghost portrait of the fat lady and he
was left there to rot for an astonishing
12 years
he was eventually able to escape the
island fortress by turning into his
animagus form a black dog and squeezing
through the bars
there are a few things that i always
found interesting about sirius's
imprisonment first of all why didn't he
get a proper trial all the death eaters
did bellatrix the woman with the heavy
lidded eyes looked up at crouch and
called the dark lord will rise again
crouch throw us into azkaban we will
wait he will rise again and will come
for us he will reward us beyond any of
his other supporters we alone were
faithful we alone tried to find him and
then kakaroth crouch is going to let him
out moody breathed quietly to dumbledore
he's done a deal with him it took me six
months to track him down and crouch is
going to let him go if he's got enough
new names let's hear his information i
say and throw him straight back to the
dementors and even snape who switched
sides towards the end of the war and
pledged allegiance to dumbledore was
simply acquitted of his crimes on
dumbledore's word
snape has been cleared by this council
said crouch disdainfully he has been
vouched for by albus dumbledore
so my question is this if dumbledore's
word was enough to clear a former death
eater of all charges why couldn't he
have freed sirius
sirius was a former member of the order
his own organization
why couldn't anything have been done to
help him
was dumbledore convinced of sirius
innocence or was a veil pulled over his
eyes just like everyone else if we look
at the text further we can derive some
answers from dumbledore himself
it is your turn to listen and i beg you
will not interrupt me because there is
very little time he said quietly there
is not a shred of proof to support
black's story accept your word and the
word of two thirteen-year-old wizards
will not convince anybody a street full
of eyewitnesses swore they saw serious
murder pettigrew i myself give evidence
to the ministry that sirius had been the
potter's secret keeper professor lupin
can tell you harry said unable to stop
himself
professor lupin is currently deep in the
forest unable to tell anyone anything
by the time he is human again it will be
too late sirius will be worse than dead
i might add that werewolves are so
mistrusted by most of our kind that his
support will count for very little
and the fact that he and sirius are old
friends
but
listen to me harry it is too late you
understand me you must see that
professor snape's version of events is
far more convincing than yours
he hates sirius hermione said
desperately all because of some stupid
trick sirius played on him sirius has
not acted like an innocent man
the attack on the fat lady entering
gryffindor tower with a knife without
pettigrew alive or dead we have no
chance of overturning sirius's sentence
but you believe us
yes i do said dumbledore quietly but i
have no power to make other men see the
truth or to overrule the minister of
magic
this tells us a few things
first of all dumbledore was still under
the impression that sirius black had
been secret keeper for the potters and
if this is the case it makes total sense
that he would believe that sirius was
guilty up until this point that would
have meant that he would have been the
one to reveal the potter's location next
it looks like severus snape who had
recently changed allegiances had told
dumbledore his own story about the
events of the night and i would imagine
that he too was tricked by the stunt
that pettigrew pulled off as at this
point he was being completely honest and
transparent he hated sirius but i don't
think he would have gone as far as to
frame him for that sort of crime
even when harry says to dumbledore but
you believe us and he responds yes i do
there is what seems to be a lack of
authenticity present
every other part of their conversation
still seems to suggest that dumbledore
believes he is guilty
it is not until he is given irrefutable
evidence that he firmly believes
sirius's innocence
patagru's framing of sirius was really
quite impressive it was a perfect crime
and i think that that is why he was even
able to convince the likes of snape and
dumbledore pettigrew knew right away
that he would need to be the one to
frame sirius for the betrayal of lily
and james as sirius was the only other
person that knew about him being secret
keeper everyone else was still under the
impression that it was serious better
group baited or allowed himself to be
found by sirius who was still furious
after discovering what had happened to
the potters beta group was in a muggle
town surrounded by muggles which ensured
that he wouldn't have any proper
witnesses nearby for the crime that he
was about to commit when sirius arrived
pettigrew feigned grief over the loss of
the potters but his tune quickly changed
and he promptly produced a powerful
blasting curse then before i could curse
him he blew up the street with the wand
behind his back killed everyone within
20 feet of himself and sped down into
the sewer with the other rats
besides the marauders only remus lupin
knew that pettigrew was nana magus and
so he really would have been sirius's
last hope
however lupin who was unsure of what to
think anymore felt that the evidence
against sirius was too strong
and didn't say a word pettigrew had
cunningly chopped off his own finger
before departing into the sewer which he
left behind as evidence of his death
because he was dead to the world his
innocence was implicit which ensured
that all fingers pointed at sirius
there he was in a street full of dead
muggles with his former friend's finger
on the ground in front of him
surely he was guilty because fudge was
the first to appear on scene sirius was
never given a trial or any possibility
of exonerating himself
in the books he recalls the aftermath of
that evening in great detail a crater in
the middle of the street so deep it had
cracked the sewer below
bodies everywhere muggles screaming and
black standing there laughing with what
was left of pettigrew in front of him
a heap of bloodstained robes and a few a
few fragments and what's most
interesting about what fudge saw was
that sirius was laughing from the
outside he truly came across as a crazed
murderous lunatic that took pleasure in
the heinous crimes that he had committed
where in reality he was a man that
couldn't help but laugh as the world he
knew crumbled around him one of his
childhood friends was dead the other had
switched sides he was surrounded by the
bodies of muggles and now he would have
to live knowing the recommendation that
he made to the potters to make
pettigrew's secret keeper
sirius's story is truly a tragic one and
petticrew's framing of him was
exceedingly well done convincing even
albus dumbledore
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
you